Welcome students
to the Pharmacology
of the Sympathomimetics
Part 1.
This lecture will
describe the direct
acting Sympathomimetics,
those drugs that
act directly on
adrenergic receptors.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
Please contact
me if you'd like
to chat about
pharmacology, talk
about the practice
questions.
I'm available
by appointment.
Just send me an
email please.
Here are the learning
objectives. I
think you're used
to looking at them
now and you
appreciate that the
content is reflected
by these learning
objectives as will
the questions be.
Preparation materials
and links and key points.
Knowledge of the
physiology of the autonomic
nervous system is
essential, as I'm sure
you've realized, because
the core concepts
of sympasomimatic
pharmacology are built
on knowledge of the
physiologic actions,
reflex regulatory
responses of the autonomic
nervous system. And
it's important that you
become familiar with
the actual actions,
the mechanisms, and
actions signaling responses
of activating receptors
or blocking them.
I'm not going to
read you the key
points. They're
here to summarize
everything that we'll
be talking about.
You must know the
terms, as always,
the language of
medicine, the language
of pharmacology.
Going forward now,
various receptor types
and their G-protein
-coupled receptor
actions. You can see
they're all G-protein
-coupled receptors.
Please make sure
you understand
the effects of
activating these
various types
of receptors.
And sympathetic
responses are summarized
here with some
cardiovascular
terminology that you
really must understand.
I know you haven't
had cardiology
lectures yet,
vascular lectures yet.
I'm just giving you
very straightforward
actions, not all
complicated things. You
need to know about
heart rate and ******
volume, cardiac output.
I'll go over those.
You need to understand
about the resistance
in the vessel's
peripheral resistance,
total peripheral
resistance. You need
to know about mean
pressure, mean arterial
pressure, about
preload and afterload.
So if you don't
understand it from
this lecture, please
do look it up.
Systolic blood pressure,
diastolic blood
pressure. I'm sure you're
familiar with blood
pressure cuff and
taking blood pressures
showing systolic and
diastolic blood pressure.
And here are a couple
of other terms, pulse
pressure and baroreceptors.
baroreceptors,
are the signaling
of reflex responses.
And here's reflex
responses and
changes to blood
pressure. Slow heart
rate, bradycardia.
Fast heart rate,
tachycardia.
And renin. I put the
pronunciation here for
you. Renin as in
renal because renin is
secreted from specialized
cells in the kidney.
Just a very quick
brief and simple
review to show to
remind you about the
sympathetic nervous
system and actions.
Sympathetic nervous
system ganglia are
located paraspinally
and they have these long
postganglionic neurons
to the effector cells.
The adrenergic
neurotransmitters,
by and large,
is norepinephrine,
and epinephrine, which
comes out of the adrenal
medulla, is a hormone
that acts on the
adrenergic receptors.
the adrenal medulla
is part of the
sympathetic nervous
system but it has a
nicotinic receptor so
the neurotransmitter
there is acetylcholine
the sweat glands
are also part of
the sympathetic
nervous system but
have cholinergic
muscarinic receptors
that activate them i'm
not going to go
over this line by
line. I've labeled
the receptors and
which receptors are
expressed on these
various tissues.
I take you down
here to really, this
is the takeaway.
The pattern.
Stimulation of
alpha-1 receptors
on smooth muscle causes
contraction. Alpha
-1 contraction.
Stimulation of
beta-2 receptors on
smooth muscle
causes relaxation,
beta 2 relaxation.
Those are the
takeaways. With
this whole chart,
I think you will
see the pattern.
Vasculature with
alpha 1 activation,
constriction.
Vasculature with
beta 2 activation,
relaxation. And
so too for smooth
muscle on other types
of organ systems.
The heart is
regulated through
sympathetic and
parasympathetic.
Parasympathetic
is here, so PNS,
via M2 receptors,
which slows
heart, slows AV
conduction. On the
other side, beta
-2 receptors,
I'm sorry, beta-1
receptors, beta-1
receptors in the SA
node and AV node will
increase heart rate and
increase conduction.
And on the heart
muscle itself
that increases
contraction.
So I put this down
here in this box so you
can see what happens
when the beta-1
receptors are stimulated
in the heart. A number
of different things
as you can see but
basically the heart
is working harder and
as the heart beats
faster and squeezes with
more force it forces
more blood into the
vessels, into the
aorta, in a shorter
amount of time than
the resting heart does.
And innervation of
blood vessels here.
The takeaways I put
in the box here.
Stimulation of
alpha-1 receptors on
vascular smooth
muscle induces
vasoconstriction. It is
the alpha-1 receptors
that are the
predominant types of
adrenergic receptors
on blood vessels.
Stimulation of postsynaptic
alpha 2 receptors
on blood vessels can
induce vasoconstriction.
Also they're not
nearly as numerous but
they are present and
that is the one thing
that seems a little
confusing. We know that
alpha-2 adrenergic
receptors are the G
-inhibitory type of
protein-coupled receptors.
But located
postsynaptically on
vessels, they will
cause constriction,
and this is through
a side mechanism.
And stimulation of
beta-2 receptors
on the skeletal
muscle, as I said
before, causes smooth
muscle relaxation.
Here we have the
adrenal medulla with
epinephrine and
norepinephrine being
secreted into the
bloodstream when activated
by the sympathetic
nervous system.
Normally there
is a much greater
amount of
epinephrine that is
secreted into
the bloodstream.
And this you
can just have
a look at this
figure that
This is the
point I want to
make. This is
the takeaway.
And I've set out
here the factors that
regulate cardiac output.
As I mentioned before,
when the heart is
stimulated by the
sympathetic nervous system,
the heart rate speeds
up, the conduction
speeds up, the force
of contraction is
stronger and as a result
more blood will be
pushed out of the left
ventricle into the aorta
in a shorter amount
of time. And that's
the cardiac output.
How much blood is
pushed out in a given
amount of time. So
clearly that's going to
be related to heart
rate and it will also be
related to ******
volume, ****** volume.
So how much
blood is in the
ventricle and
the heart rate.
And I've said
it all out here.
Preload and
afterload are terms
that you're going
to learn about.
Afterload to help you
is just the pressure
that the blood being pushed
out of the ventricles
is encountering in
the blood vessels.
So as the blood is pushed
out of the ventricle,
if the vessels are
all contracted, there
will be a stronger
pressure to push against
than when the vessels
are less contracted.
Then the afterload
will be lower. So
high total peripheral
volume, pushing
against that pressure,
there will be a
higher afterload
than when pushing
against a lower
pressure in the vessels.
So let's talk about
the drugs now.
I will take time to
explain all of these
things so that you
can just follow along
with me and hopefully
it will help you to
understand this somewhat
complex activities
of the Sympathomimetics.
I have the
synthesis, well I
have them all listed
here on the side with
the synthetic mechanisms.
and it's all related
to each other.
Tyrosine is a
precursor. It's used to
form DOPA, which you
may have heard of.
DOPA forms dopamine,
and let's take
a look at what's
happening here.
Here we have a carboxyl
group, here we have none.
So this is an
aromatic L-amino acid
decarboxylase enzyme.
It just takes that
carboxyl group off and
that forms dopamine.
Now what are
we doing here?
We are adding a
hydroxyl group
and that forms
norepinephrine.
And here we are
adding a methyl
group and that
forms epinephrine.
And so on.
Here are the
various drugs in
this little
flow chart. I've
put a couple of
labels on here.
The adrenergic
agonists, that's
basically what they
all are. They're
activating the adrenergic
nervous system.
The direct acting
ones are, as you
would expect, bind
to the receptor
and activate the
signaling cascade.
We have several
of them here,
several of them
here. The selective
ones, meaning they
selectively bind to
particular adrenergic
receptors, and
the non-selective
obviously bind more
than one type of
adrenergic receptor.
taking you over here
to the right hand side
now the indirect acting
don't directly bind
the adrenergic
receptors but they cause
a release and increased
concentrations of
norepinephrine in the
synapse and norepinephrine
will now do the
action so that's the
indirect part and now
mixed acting is has
both direct and indirect
actions so that's how
the adrenergic agonists
are categorized.
Let's take a look
now at the structure
activity relationship
and I think you can
see just even looking
at this chart on
the left hand side
that the structures are
all so similar to
each other which one
would expect because
they all have to fit
into the adrenergic
receptors, and there
is a flow to it. So
let's take a look
at the initial
product, the initial
compounds. This is
called phenyl ethylamine.
Phenyl ethylamine.
This is called catechol.
So these are catechol
amines, dopamine,
norepinephrine,
and epinephrine.
We'll go to dopamine
first because that's
really the next one
in the synthetic flow.
So what happens
here? We have our
phenylethylamine and the
catechol stuck onto it.
Simple, simple.
Then norepinephrine
was next, after
dopamine, with the
appropriate enzyme, as this
hydroxyl group is
put on, and so forth.
So looking at epinephrine
now, we have this
methyl substitution
on the norepinephrine,
and what does that
do? Okay, structure,
where's the activity?
that enhances
the beta-2
activity. The methyl
group enhances the
beta-2 activity.
So we see with
isoproteranol, which is a
drug, it doesn't occur
naturally in the body,
there are now two
methyl groups. One, two.
And that enhances
the beta adrenergic
receptor activity on
both beta-1 and beta-2.
And it has really no
clinically significant
activity at the
alpha receptors.
Methyl beta. Methyl beta.
Now looking at
phenylephrine, phenylephrine
is missing this
hydroxyl group,
so how does that
change the structure?
So this is basically
epinephrine
without this
hydroxyl group.
So we have resistance
to metabolism by
catechol-O
-methyltransferase, catechol
-O-methyltransferase,
you're going to
get a methyl group, and
that will inactivate
catecholamines, I
should say here.
so the phenylephrine
is resistant to COMT
it doesn't have that
location where the
methyl group goes and
it just so happens
because it's got this
hydroxyl group and it has
complete alpha-1
adrenergic receptor
selectivity with very
low beta affinity even
though it's got this
muscle group on here.
And next, these
two on the bottom,
ephedrine and
amphetamine are indirect
acting. Well,
ephedrine is the mixed
acting and amphetamine
is an indirect acting.
They have this
methyl substitution
here, this alpha
carbon, and that's going
to increase the
lipophilicity. So what
does that say?
Increase CNS activity.
Also increased oral
bioavailability.
And the methyl
substitution at the alpha
carbon gives resistance
to monoamine oxidase.
Monoamine, these
are all monoamines,
monoamine oxidase
inactivates the
catecholamines.
But now amphetamine
and ephedrine are
not inactivated
by MAO because of
that methyl group.
Plus, now this accounts
for the action,
these two drugs
displace norepinephrine
from storage
sites. Then the
norepinephrine gets
pushed into the synapse
and norepinephrine
does the work.
I never ask you to
write out structures.
What you need to know for
me is what does it mean?
What does the structure
mean for the activity?
Keep it simple.
Alright, this is a
chart of the direct
acting sympathomimetics
in terms of their
therapeutic actions,
the therapeutic uses
I should say. So we
have vasopressors,
vaso means vasculature
or vessels,
vasculature, and
pressor means pressing.
So these cause
vasoconstriction,
which increases
blood pressure,
vasopressor, sometimes
just called pressors.
And inotropes,
so inotrope is
the force of
contraction of the
heart muscle,
the myocardium.
These drugs are
inotropes. They increase
the myocardial force
of contraction.
Bronchodilators, I'm
sure you recognize what
that is. They cause
dilation of the bronchial
smooth muscle, relaxation
of the bronchial
smooth muscle, dilation
of the bronchi.
So what receptor
is that? This
is a little
review. We talked
about it in a
previous lecture.
Beta-2. Beta-2
relaxation of smooth
muscle, even if you
didn't know, thinking
about relaxation of
smooth muscle should
take you right to
the beta-2 receptors.
Mirabegrin and Bibegrin.
This is beta-3.
And then the alpha-2
agonists that we'll
talk about are clonidine
and methyl dopa.
So let's talk first
about the vasopressors.
These are powerful
drugs that raise
blood pressure. They
raise the mean arterial
pressure by inducing
vasoconstriction.
Vasoconstriction, alpha,
alpha-1 especially.
Vasopressors
are used in the
treatment of
shock, which is a
life-threatening
hypotension
that can lead
to a circulatory
failure, and it is
a medical emergency.
So epinephrine,
norepinephrine, dopamine,
phenylephrine are, for
emergency situations,
hypotension.
How are they
different? Well,
it's their relative
affinities for the
adrenergic receptors
that make them different.
We'll start with
epinephrine. It
is a potent
stimulator of all
alpha types and
all beta types.
The relative affinities
are beta 1 and
beta 2 greater than
alpha 1 and alpha
2. That said, don't
forget that it's still
a potent stimulant
of the alpha
receptors as well as
the beta. But it will
preferentially bind
the beta receptors.
And this is all, as
with so many drugs,
dose-dependent
effects. Well,
to understand epinephrine,
the pharmacologic
epinephrine effects,
we need to really
understand epinephrine
physiologic effects.
So I'm going to take
you through that now
in the fight or flight
response. So this
is when the person
is in a situation of
really an emergency to
get out or to fight,
the adrenal medulla
will be signaled
and will secrete
epinephrine.
And don't forget,
all natural actions
are regulated. So it
will secrete epinephrine
as needed in the
concentration
that is needed for
the situation at hand.
So when this happens,
especially at this
high fight-or-flight
response level,
epinephrine is
traveling through the
bloodstream, stimulating
the beta-1 receptors,
and what happens then?
Increased heart rate,
increased strength
of contraction, and
that's going to increase
the ****** volume
and increase the
cardiac output. And
the coronary blood
flow is also going to
increase because
after all the heart is
a muscle that needs
to be fed by blood.
And it can
actually lead to
arrhythmia with all
of this increase
in activity in the heart.
Well, in fight or
flight, the person needs
to be able to take
in great breaths,
great amounts of air.
So that's beta 2 on
the respiratory system,
bronchodilation.
Blood pressure increases.
Usually the diastolic
pressure decreases,
and I'll go through
why that happens.
And the mean
arterial pressure
only slightly changes.
might even decrease.
I'll go through
why that happens.
And there's
an increase in
the mean pulmonary
pressure. That's
a vascular effect.
Peripheral circulation,
I'll take you
down here now.
Because SBP is
increasing and
diastolic pressure
is decreasing.
That's where
this comes in and
that's where there
may be an unchanged
total peripheral
resistance or
it might even be
a little lower.
There's going
to be a little
increase in
cerebral blood flow.
More blood is
coming that way.
Definitely an increase
in skeletal muscle
blood flow and
that's because of
vasodilation by
activation of the beta 2
receptors. When a
person's in a fight
-or-flight response,
skeletal muscles
need to be fed with
blood and nutrients.
The beta-2s are
not anywhere else.
They're only in the
skeletal muscle. So
in other areas of
blood flow, the skin,
the splanchnic
vessels, the kidneys,
the visceral, the
viscera, there are only
alphas. So think
about how this is
happening. There's
vasoconstriction there,
but vasodilation in
the skeletal muscle,
so the blood is going
to be shunted towards
the skeletal muscle,
where it's really
needed at this moment.
It's not so much
needed in the skin
or in the mesentery.
increased oxygen
consumption the person
is working hard needs
more needs and that
oxygen is being
consumed blood glucose
goes up also lactic
acid goes up and
plasma potassium goes
down i'm not going
to go through those
mechanisms and i'm
not asking you to
remember them for this
lecture. You'll learn
about them later.
In the CNS, there's
increased respiration,
so increased oxygen
consumption, and
increased, so the patient
is feeling things,
subjective sensations,
feeling anxiety,
feeling alarm, and
the immune system
is also affected.
There are various
immunomodulatory
actions that I'm also
not going to go through
in this lecture.
I will be
concentrating on the
cardio, vascular, and
pulmonary effects.
So let's talk
about the drug now.
We'll overlay
epinephrine pharmacologic
actions on to the
physiologic actions. Once
you know the physiology,
you'll know the
pharmacology. So there
are dose-dependent
effects in the
vasculature. When we're
talking about dose,
epinephrine is given in,
experimentally anyway,
and occasionally
in humans
at a continuous infusion.
So the drug is just
going in, going in,
going in. At this
point I would like
to say therapeutically
I am as much
preferred. We'll talk
about that later.
But for the sake of
understanding epinephrine's
cardiovascular
effects, we'll talk
about it in this dose
-dependent fashion.
So low doses.
So a very low amount
of epinephrine going
in per minute, being
by continuous infusion.
it's going to act
preferentially on beta 2
receptors in the
skeletal muscle so what
what will that cause
vasodilation in the
skeletal muscle vascular
beds and what will
that cause a decrease
in the total peripheral
resistance because
the the blood pressure
comes from the
pressure of the blood
pressing against the
vasculature. So when the
vessels are dilated,
there's going to be
less pressure against
the vessels, so the
blood pressure is
lower. When the vessels
are constricted,
there's more pressure of
that blood against
the vessels, so the
pressure will be higher.
So what we're talking
about here with the
vasodilation and the
skeletal muscle vascular
beds is a decrease
in the total peripheral
resistance and
also a decrease in
diastolic blood pressure
just like we see with
natural epinephrine.
What's happening
on the alpha side?
Well the beta 2s are
only in the skeletal
muscle vasculature
but the blood is
everywhere so there's
vasoconstriction and
all the other areas
just like natural
epinephrine. So the
blood is being shunted
from these other
areas to the skeletal
muscle vascular
beds. Now high dose
epinephrine and I'm
skipping through the
medium dose causes
vasoconstriction alpha
vasoconstrictive alpha
effects predominantly
high dose so you
get this profound
increase in mean arterial
pressure profound
vasoconstriction
and it's dangerous
okay what's happening
in the heart
increased heart
rate so that's
called a
chronotropic effect
positive
Increased
conduction velocity,
that's what we expect.
Increased strength
in ventricular
contraction, and
that's called
inotropy, positive
inotropic action.
And an increase in
ventricular work per
beat, meaning that
it's using more oxygen.
And as the muscle
uses more oxygen, it
needs to be supplied
by the coronary
vessels. So people who
have coronary artery
disease in which
their vessels are
either occluded or
partially occluded, by
increasing that oxygen
demand can cause
an ischemic attack
in these patients.
Okay, so we talked
about low dose, the
beta-2 mediated
enhanced blood flow. I
have this chart on
the right hand side.
Epinephrine is
administered at this
point where the
arrow is located.
And that will
cause an increase
in systolic
blood pressure,
but it will
cause a decrease
in diastolic
blood pressure.
And so there's very
little change in
the mean arterial
pressure, a little
bit of a decrease
in this sketch.
But let's look
at the heart now.
So this is beta 1.
This is beta 2 down here.
And this is
alpha 1 up here.
Oh, beta-1,
what am I doing,
beta-1 because
we're getting that
increase in
cardiac output.
And also remember that
blood is shunting, is
being shunted towards
the skeletal muscle.
So the heart, that's
mainly beta-1 by far.
Well, the heart rate
is going to increase
as those beta receptors
get stimulated.
And also the
cardiac muscle
is going to be
pumping harder.
So to recap, beta
2 mediated enhanced
blood flow to
skeletal muscles will
decrease the
peripheral resistance
and decrease diastolic
blood pressure.
Beta-1, increased
heart rate,
increased force
of contraction.
So, of course, those
two together will
increase heart rate
and increased ******
volume, coming from
an increased force
of contraction, will
increase cardiac
output and, of course,
oxygen demand. And the
mean arterial blood
pressure is usually
not greatly elevated
because of this
difference in dilation
of the skeletal muscle
vasculature versus
the non-skeletal
muscle vasculature.
Intermediate rate.
Well, it's going to get
more alpha. Basically,
that's what it's
talking about, and that
can cause an increase
in blood pressure,
which can stimulate
the compensatory
reflexes in order to
push down, in order to
decrease heart rate.
and why would the
heart rate be decreased
in this compensatory
reflex in order to
reduce the ****** volume
and reduce the cardiac
output so that that
will have less effect
on the blood pressure
now rapid intravenous
infusion i mentioned
it before and it
can be mentioned many
many times before,
later it is
that important.
Predominantly the
alpha effects now,
so blood pressure
is going to go up,
diastolic blood
pressure is going to go
up, mean arterial
pressure is going
to go up, we have
this pressor effect.
And we'll get this
reflex homeostatic
adjustments, meaning
the parasympathetic
system is triggered
to send a message down
to the heart to
decrease the heart rate.
Pharmacokinetics.
Usually I put this first,
but I wanted to connect
the mechanism of
action of epinephrine
pharmacology to
epinephrine physiology.
So let's talk about
the pharmacokinetics
now. IM, this is
preferred, preferred
method of administration.
Sub-Q can be, it can
be used subcutaneously,
it can be used IV if
necessary, it can be
put into the bone
intraosseous if necessary.
An alternative to
the IM for emergent
use, people carry
it around in their
pockets, in their bags
is intranasal spray
which I have a
picture down here and
it can also be
given ****** by oral
inhalation and what's
for inhaled where
is it going to go
the lungs so beta 2
bronchodilation makes
sense doesn't it I
will reiterate
yet again IV and
IO root only if
immediate reliable
effect is required
because it as in profound
hypotension or
cardiopulmonary arrest.
This is a catecholamine,
it is polar,
it's not absorbed from
the GI tract. They
do not cross the
blood-brain barrier.
So how are they degraded?
Monoamine oxidase and
catecholomethyltransferase
in many
many tissues but there's
a high concentration
of these enzymes
in the liver.
Metabolites, small
amount of the
unchanged drug goes
excreted in the urine,
not much because
of the efficient
metabolic process.
High levels of
epinephrine, norepinephrine
and metabolites in the
blood and urine are
indicative of this tumor,
which is an adrenal
tumor called
pheochromocytoma and we'll be
talking more about that
in the next lecture.
Not part two
but in the in
the adrenergic
antagonists.
So okay great we have
an emergent situation.
How fast are
these drugs going
to act by these
various routes.
I am very rapidly.
It comes in an auto
-injector. People can
inject themselves.
Bystanders can
inject it easily and
it works very rapidly.
Subcutaneously,
it's going to take
several minutes.
Intranasal spray,
very easy to use.
Anybody can use that
easily, and it will
take about a minute to
achieve an onset. IV, of
course, it's immediate,
but only people who
are experienced with
the use of intravenous
epinephrine should
administer it that way,
and it should be in
an area where there is
support in case it's
needed all right what
do we use it for well
whenever you see a
drug of choice make
sure to file that away
in your brain i am an
intranasal spray without
delay for anaphylactic
shock reversal so
when a person is
having an allergic
reaction a severe allergic
reaction they can have
rapid hypotension.
Their throats can swell
up and they'll have
difficulty breathing.
The bronchi will
constrict and the person
can die really in a
matter of minutes. So
this is why epinephrine
should be used without
delay. And epinephrine
is the drug of choice,
never contraindicated
when we're treating
anaphylaxis. So
why? Why would this
be the drug of choice?
Because, one,
rapid action.
Two,
it will open the airways.
Three, it has the
beta-2 action.
But more importantly,
it has the
alpha-1 constricting
effect that
will bring up the
blood pressure
at the dose that
it is given I am.
And that will be the
predominant effect.
So those are the main
reasons and it will
have an effect on the
immune system too, but
as I said I'm not
going to go into that.
Well adverse effects.
Think about fight
or flight if you want
to. It might help.
Restlessness,
apprehension,
just the fear that
something's
going to happen.
Throbbing headache,
tremor, the arms
and the hands and
arms and legs are
shaking. The heart
is beating like mad.
********* ventricular
contractions can
occur with this
with pharmacologic
epinephrine. Patient
has to be observed for
that when it's given
IV particularly.
Arrhythmias, angina
in patients who
have coronary artery
disease, cerebral
hemorrhage because
there's going to be
this sharp increase
in blood pressure.
Continuous use, well
sometimes it has to
be used continuously
when a person is
in severe shock and
the continuous use
can lead to severe
hypertension and cardiac
complications. It
only makes sense.
Adverse effects include
sympathetic
stimulation. Well,
that's its job, but it's
also an adverse effect.
And
extravasation, meaning
the drug can leak
out of the infusion
site because we poke a
hole in that vessel to
get the drug in and it
can leak out and and
that can cause severe
constriction of the
local blood vessels
that can prevent nutrients
and oxygen getting
to the tissues, causing
tissue necrosis.
Let's check our
knowledge on this one.
I invite you to
pause your computer
and think about this
for a minute. it.
Where is Epi synthesized
and secreted from
in the periphery? That's
what we're talking
about right now. What
are Epi's relative
affinities for the
adrenergic receptor types?
And what are the
effects of physiologic
epinephrine on blood
pressure, chronotropy,
inotropy, and peripheral
vascular resistance?
It is synthesized
in the adrenal
medulla from
norepinephrine. So
norepinephrine has
to be present there.
Phenylethanolamine
N-methyltransferase
converts norepinephrine
to epinephrine and
I gave you a little
structure here on the
right-hand side so
you can visualize it.
It's the N
-methyltransferase which is
present obviously in
the adrenal medulla.
If PNMT is not present,
then norepinephrine
is not going to convert
to epinephrine, such
as in the synapses,
in the nerve synapses.
What are epinephrine's
relative affinities?
Well, beta 1 and beta
2 equal affinity,
greater affinity than
alpha 1 and alpha 2,
strong for all of them,
but it will have a
preferential effect
on beta 1 and beta 2.
and that's where
their predominant
effect will be unless
there's a high
dose epinephrine.
And the effects,
increased chronotropy,
increased sinotropy,
rise in cardiac
output, increased
systolic blood pressure,
vasodilation in
skeletal muscle beds,
decreased peripheral
resistance and
decreased diastolic
blood pressure,
Mean arterial pressure
is not usually
greatly elevated,
usually flat or lower.
But that's
dose dependent.
If it's a high
dose, mean arterial
pressure will go
up and that will
stimulate the reflex
actions to reverse
heart rate. But
lower dose, no.
Increased heart
rate, increased
****** volume,
increased cardiac
output, constriction
of veins.
And as the veins
constrict, that's going
to push the blood
back to the heart.
So, increased venous
return to the heart.
And that, in turn,
is going to increase
****** volume and
cardiac output.
Makes sense, right? Each
one follows on the other.
Epi in high dose or
continuous infusion
causes vasoconstriction
and increased
total peripheral
resistance. The
epinephrine is
the drug of choice
for what
condition and why?
Anaphylaxis,
anaphylactic shock, which
is hypotension due to
widespread vasodilation
and vascular
leakage leading to
reduce flow to organs
and organ failure.
Why is it the
drug of choice?
Because it works
fast, prevents
progression of symptoms,
causes bronchodilation,
so opens the airways,
causes vasoconstriction,
increases the
force of contraction,
so that's going to
increase the blood pressure,
and vasoconstriction
also reduces
allergic angioedema,
that's the throat
swelling, and hives, and
suppresses release of
histamine and other
mediators from mast
cells. It's nice to know.
I'm not going to test you
specifically on
that at this point.
But it's sort of
thing that you might
see in a stem that
gives you a hint.
So let's talk about
norepinephrine now.
Potent stimuli of
alpha to alpha 1 and
alpha 2 and beta 1
adrenergic receptors.
So I put it here
in comparison to
epinephrine, alpha-1,
alpha-2, and beta-1.
Very little,
really no clinical
effect on beta-2s.
Epinephrine is
stronger, though, than
norepinephrine on the
alphas, just to give
you a sense of the
potency of epinephrine.
Beta-1 epinephrine
has a stronger
effect on the beta-1s
than norepinephrine
does, and beta
-2 we know it's
epinephrine is
beta-2 all the way.
So if you know
what receptors are
being activated
then you can
predict and look
for those effects.
So is norepinephrine
going to cause
bronchodilation? No.
Is norepinephrine going
to cause dilation
in the vascular in
the skeletal muscle
vascular beds? No.
So, potent vasopressor.
It will activate
all of the alphas in
the in the vascular
system everywhere
and that's going
to increase total
peripheral resistance
and therefore the
blood coming out of the
left ventricle is
going to be pushing
against that peripheral
resistance so
So it's going to
increase the afterload.
So constricting of
the veins increases
return to the heart
because it's pushing
the blood back to
the heart. And that's
going to increase the
preload. When more
blood comes back
into the heart, that
increases the preload,
pre before heart.
And if more blood
is coming back in,
that's going to increase
the ****** volume.
One step follows
the next.
cardiac effects well
it does have a powerful
effect on beta 1
receptors even though
it may not be as
great as epinephrine
it's still powerful
so that will increase
cardiac force of
contraction on the muscles
but it has a modest
increase in cardiac
output and I'll
explain that a little
later. And it
increases mean arterial
pressure naturally
because it's increasing.
It's causing
vasoconstriction all over.
And that is going to
induce that reflex
effect to decrease
the heart rate.
Parasympathetic
signal comes down to
the heart. The M2
receptors are stimulated.
That decreases
the heart rate,
decreases the conduction
through the AV
node, decreases the
atrial contractions.
Adverse, I should
say, decreases the
strength of the
atrial contractions.
Adverse effects are
typical of the class.
Reduced flow to
the organs because
everything is
vasoconstricted. So that's
going to decrease
organ perfusion. And
what happens when we
decrease perfusion?
danger of organ failure.
Ventricular arrhythmia as
we stimulate that heart.
Digital ischemia
because we're
constricting all
of those vessels in
the in the little
fingers and toes.
Extravasation at the
injection site the
same way as we see
with any vasopressor.
So where is
norepinephrine
synthesized and
secreted from.
It is synthesized
in presynaptic
adrenergic
neurons. It's the
neurotransmitter from
the presynaptic neurons.
And it is stored in
vesicles in those
neurons and it's
released into the synapse
when it gets a signal
down the sympathetic
neuron where it
will activate the
adrenergic receptors
in the effector organs.
Dopamine is the precursor
to norepinephrine.
Dopamine beta hydroxylase
is the enzyme.
I'm not going to ask
you these enzymes.
Norepinephrine is
also synthesized in
the adrenal medulla
and secreted into the
bloodstream normally
in small amounts.
And the relative
affinities are alpha
1 and alpha 2 are
equal to each other,
greater than
beta 1 affinity,
although still potent,
and the beta 2 activity
is very, very low.
And the effects?
Vasoconstriction
all over.
Global vasoconstriction
increases
total peripheral
resistance
increases systolic
blood pressure,
increases diastolic
increased force
of contraction of
the heart muscle,
that's inotropy,
increased ******
volume with a
modest increase
in cardiac output.
An increase in mean
arterial pressure
because of the vagal,
the compensatory vagal
reflex overcomes the
direct stimulation
of heart rate. So that
is the explanation
of why there's only
a modest increase in
cardiac output. It's
because of the reflex
vagal, the vagal
reflex that slows the
heart rate. So as the
norepinephrine is put
into the vein, it
travels to the heart,
it causes that initial
thump, thump, thump,
thump, but then as it
increases the total
peripheral resistance
and mean arterial
pressure, the
parasympathetic nervous
system is signaled to
lower the heart rate.
So what do we use
it for? Shock.
Really, it's preferred
for most types of shock.
And why? Why
is it a drug of
choice? And we
should always know
that. The answer
is evidence.
Clinical experience
of norepinephrine's
effectiveness in the
treatment of shock.
Potent vasoconstriction
increases
systemic vascular
resistance
and raises
blood pressure.
Mild increase in
cardiac output compared
to a pure alpha
-1 agonist like
phenylephrine. Lower
risk of arrhythmias
compared to dopamine
and dobutamine.
And vasopressors
are components of a
broader treatment plan.
Of course, we're not
using them by
themselves. So you may
notice on here that
epinephrine is missing.
We don't normally,
normally doesn't
mean ever,
never.
Normally we don't
use epinephrine
in the treatment
of shock because
of the value of
norepinephrine.
Dopamine now, yes
dopamine peripherally.
We're talking about
dopamine. Dopamine normally
is secreted, is
synthesized in specialized
renal cells and
secreted, and it has
particular actions in
the peripheral system.
It will act on D1,
well at least in terms
of the drug, we're
thinking about
action on D1, alpha-1,
and beta-1 receptors.
So what are the
relative affinities?
Dopamine, of course
it has a strong
affinity for dopamine
receptors, but
it also has some
affinity for beta
-1 receptors and
alpha-1 receptors.
You may have noticed the
similarities in
their structures.
Alpha-1 epinephrine
is the most potent,
norepinephrine is
very potent, and
dopamine less so.
So this effect is
going to be dose
dependent. How much of
that dopamine is
in the vasculature
and getting to the
alpha-1 receptors.
Epinephrine has
more has a stronger
affinity for the
beta ones although
they're both potent
and norep and
dopamine actually
has equal affinity
to norepinephrine
for the beta ones.
And beta 2,
dopamine basically
really has no
clinical effect.
Dose dependent, I
keep talking about
dose dependent
effects. So these are
the hemodynamic
effects. I've given
you this chart to
kind of remind you
about fundamental
pharmacokinetics.
This is drug concentration.
This is effect.
So this is the
lowest. This is the
highest concentration
of dopamine in
the blood in micrograms
per milliliter.
This is a
continuous infusion.
At low dose, the
dopamine 1 activation,
because it does strong
affinity for dopamine
1, in the renal and
mesenteric vessels, that's
where the dopamine 1
receptors are located,
will cause vasodilation.
vasodilation.
So that will increase
renal blood flow
and an increase in
the amount of blood
flowing into the
glomerulus is going
to increase the
glomerular filtration
rate and the
activation of D1 also
causes increased
sodium excretion. So as
the vessels in the
renal and mesentery
dilate, that's going
to be a decrease in
the peripheral vascular
resistance. See
how that flows?
Well, what could that
be useful for? Well,
we don't use low-dose
dopamine for its
hemodynamic effects.
So intermediate dosing.
It's a little
bit higher dose.
Beta-1 activation
now, So we're
getting the dopamine
plus the beta 1.
And what's that going
to do? Increased
heart rate,
increased strength of
contraction, positive
inotropic effects.
So there will be
an increase in
systolic blood pressure
as the heart is
beating faster and
pushing more out.
and total peripheral
resistance is usually
unchanged because we
have this balance now
between the effects
on the heart and this
vasodilatory effects
of activation of D1.
But high dose, I
have that right here,
we get the alpha-1
activation now. So
there's going
to be a vascular
constriction generally
throughout the body
and that will have
the presser effect,
dose-dependent effects.
Now, one may
say, okay, what a
great idea. We
can use that shock
because the kidneys
will be spared.
And studies
have been done
to examine that
hypothesis.
But dopamine was
associated with higher
mortality and
dysrhythmias were more
common. And this
is from a subgroup
analysis from a
randomized clinical trial.
Dopamine does not
appear to provide
any renal protective
advantage over
routine therapy
with IV diuretics.
So no, the evidence
demonstrates
that really it
doesn't have the
benefit that was
expected. it.
So let's talk about
phenylephrine now.
It's an alpha-1
selective vasopressor.
It is not a
catecholamine because
it's missing that
hydroxyl group on
the phenyl group,
on the phenyl ring.
I put the pharmacokinetics
here in the
front. They're very
simple. It is given
******. It doesn't
have really very much
effect at the doses
that it's given.
IV IM
subcutaneously
intranasally.
Intranasal is just
for stuffy nose.
IV IM sub Q obviously
this would be for
systemic and it can
also be put into
the eye drops and
this is for red eyes.
So looking at each
of these routes
of administration
should tell
you what it's
being used for.
Metabolism in the
liver, in the gut wall,
monoamine oxidase,
sulfation,
glucuronidation.
Oral bioavailability is
Okay,
not great.
Half-life, IV,
pretty short
half-life, 15 minutes.
IM or sub-Q, it
takes a little longer
to get into the
bloodstream, so
it takes a little
longer to get out.
And when we put it
into the I, well,
it's not going to
be metabolized that
quickly, so it
lasts a bit longer.
What's it do? Well,
it's pure alpha
-1. What does that
tell you? Potent
vasoconstriction,
and potent
vasoconstriction all
over the body is going
to increase
peripheral resistance,
increase systolic blood
pressure, increase
diastolic blood
pressure. And so as the
pressure goes up, the
mean arterial pressure
goes up, that triggers
the reflex effect
to lower the heart rate,
and that may decrease
the ****** volume. It
depends. Everything
is dose dependent.
So what is it? It's
a vasopressor. That's
what we use it for.
IV. For the treatment
of hypotension.
When? Well we know
it's not first line
because that's
norepinephrine. So it's an
alternative in
patients who cannot
take norepinephrine
or who have failed
other therapies.
Nasal congestion. That's
when we're putting
it in the nose and
it's also ****** in OTC
cough and cold products,
but it doesn't work
too well as a nasal
decongestant for that.
It can be sprayed into
the nose, intranasal,
and that works
nicely. It causes
vasoconstriction in
the vessels of the
mucous membranes in
the nose, and that will
cause them to shrink,
making more room
within that little
nasal space within
the nares, and
therefore breathing is
easier and but if
it's used for a long
term, long term can
be two or three days,
continuously when
it is removed from
the receptors it
can cause rebound
congestion that can
be quite strong.
And red eyes, it
has the same effect
in the eyes. It causes
vasoconstriction
which takes the red
out of the eyes.
It can be used as eye drops
by the ophthalmologist
to cause medriasis.
Alpha-1 effect
can be used as a hemostat
because it's obviously
it's going to stop
some local bleeding.
And it's actually
in hemorrhoid
products for the
same reason to
cause a local
vasoconstriction and
shrink the size
of those vessels.
What are the dose
-dependent effects of
intravenous dopamine
infusion on blood
pressure, chronotropy,
inotropy, peripheral
vascular resistance?
What are the
effects of intravenous
phenylephrine infusion
on blood pressure,
chronotropy, inotropy,
and peripheral
vascular resistance?
And what are the
clinical indications
for dopamine and
phenylephrine.
Okay.
With regard to
dopamine infusion,
low-dose D1 activation
in the renal and
mesoteric vessels,
which is where the
D1s are expressed, will
cause vasodilation,
increase renal
blood flow, GFR, and
will increase
sodium excretion and
decrease peripheral
vascular resistance. Try
and see this as a
large effect. Imagine
it as a large effect
that's happening
because of the
vasodilating effect.
Except for the
sodium excretion,
that's a second
action that it does.
Intermediate doses,
we have our beta
-1s now. What happens
when we stimulate
the beta-1 receptors
in the heart.
Increased heart
rate, increased AV
conduction, increased
force of contraction,
and it just so
happens it causes
norepinephrine
release from the
nerve terminals,
an indirect effect
that I forgot to
mention earlier.
In any case, we're
increasing the systolic
blood pressure because
we're increasing
the cardiac output.
The diastolic
pressure may be the
same because of the
vasodilatory effect
in the mesentery and
kidneys, or it could
be slightly increased.
What are the effects
of phenylephrine
infusion? Generalized
vasoconstriction.
Alpha, pure one,
alpha one. That's it.
And the indications
for use,
alternatives to
norepinephrine for
severe hypotension.
So this is going
to be patient
specific decision.
And phenylephrine
topically will reduce
congestion by causing
local vasoconstriction.
Let's talk now about
isoproteranol
and dobutamine.
These are positive
inotropes now. What
are we looking at?
We're looking at
the force of
cardiomyocyte contraction.
So let's talk
about these drugs.
Isopraterinol first.
So what do you
notice about
the mechanism
of activity.
Relative affinities.
Potent non-selective
beta adrenergic receptor
agonist with activity
at beta 1, beta
2, and beta 3, but
that's it. Only beta.
I should put the
structure here. You may
remember that it's
like epinephrine but
It was two methyl
groups on the nitrogen.
The beta-1 activity
of isoproteranol
is even stronger
than epinephrine
and norepinephrine
and dopamine.
The beta-2 activity
is also stronger than
that of epinephrine
and the others. Well,
the others have very
little beta-2 action.
So what would we use
it for? Well, it's
got heart action,
clearly. So positive
chronotropic and
inotropic actions,
heart rate, and
force of contraction.
That's going to
increase cardiac output
and increase oxygen
consumption. Hence,
it's categorization
as an inotrope.
Beta-2 action,
of course, it'll
cause bronchial
smooth muscle
and GI smooth
muscle relaxation.
Back in the day, before
albuterol was developed,
isoproteranol was
used by inhalation to
open the bronchi of
people with asthma.
What's happening now
when we do activate
those beta-2 receptors
along with the beta-1s,
decreased peripheral
vascular resistance,
decreased
diastolic pressure,
systolic pressure may
be unchanged or rise,
and this is because
of the balancing
effect, and a decreased
mean arterial pressure.
We'll look at a
chart, and you'll be
able to see what we're
talking about here.
It really has limited
therapeutic use
nowadays. It's important
to understand the
mechanisms because it'll
help you understand
the sympathetic
nervous system effects.
But it is still
used for hypotension
that results from
bradycardia. Makes sense.
The drug does increase
the heart rate.
Reflex tachycardia
can occur.
So look at decrease
in mean arterial
pressure. What
will the reflex be?
The reflex is
to help get that
pressure up by
increasing heart rate.
So reflex tachycardia
will occur.
And when we
have an increase
in oxygen consumption,
we have to be
thinking about people
with coronary artery
disease, cardiac
ischemia, and that
increase in the
inotropic action can
lead to arrhythmias.
Dobutamine now
is used more
frequently as an
inotrope. It is a so
-called selective
beta-1 agonist.
It comes in a racemic
mixture, which
means it's got
this particular
drug. It has four
enantiomeric forms.
Potency of the
positive isomer on the
beta adrenergic
receptors is much greater
than that of the
negative isomer. and the
alpha adrenergic
effects offset each
other so that what
happens is basically the
drug becomes a so
-called selective beta
1 receptor agonist.
How does this work?
The negative isomer
is a potent alpha 1
receptor agonist. So
marked vasoconstrictor
effects. The
positive isomer is an
alpha 1 receptor antagonist
and it is believed
that this action
of the antagonist
effect offsets the
vasoconstrictor effect.
The positive isomer
is also a potent beta
1 receptor agonist
and it also has mild
action on beta-2
adrenergic receptors.
So we're going to
get a strong beta-1
response and somewhat
of a beta-2 action with
the use of dobutamine.
And of course,
again, as always,
dose-dependent effect.
So let's take a look now
at these net effects.
Dobutamine, as I said,
predominantly beta
1 receptor agonist
mild beta 2 so it
causes an increase in
cardiac contractility
increase in heart
rate that's going to
increase cardiac output
which is the point
of an inotrope get that
heart squeezing the
blood out increasing
that cardiac output
Beta-2 activating
effects may be
slightly greater
than its alpha-1
stimulating effects,
so that can result
in some vasodilation.
This is all
about balance and
predominant effects.
So what's the advantage
of dobutamine?
And we're comparing this
to the other inotrope,
isoprotirinol, for
cardiac output with
increased relative,
let me just start over,
increased cardiac output
with only a little
increase in heart
rate, and there will
be less reflex tachycardia
because the mean
arterial pressure is
not taking a drop.
So, summary
of the effect.
Increased cardiac
output, decreased
systemic vascular
resistance,
decreased central venous
pressure, you don't
have to worry about
that one, decreased
pulmonary wedge pressure,
these are preload
things, you don't have
to worry about that for
now, you will need to
know it eventually,
and improved
renal blood flow.
Low doses, dobutamine
relieves signs and
symptoms of congestive
heart failure. so
what's the use for
cardiac decompensation
so when that heart
just starts to fail
due to cardiac surgery
due to heart congestive
heart failure due
to acute mi it's
only let me put quite
a few lines under
this short-term treatment
well why is that
because of tachyphylaxis
with this drug.
Remember its major
effects is on the
beta receptors which
are known to respond
with the with
those desensitizing
mechanisms, down-regulation
of the receptors,
desensitization
of the receptors.
When do we see this?
24 to 72 hours of
continuous use. So what
are we talking? One
day to three days.
That's not a long time.
Dose-dependent rise in
systolic blood pressure
and heart rate,
hypertension, tachycardia,
angina, arrhythmia,
so these are all
potential adverse effects.
Of course the patient
is going to be
hospitalized and monitored
closely.
All right what else
could we use dobutamine
for then? Stress
testing in patients
who can't do an
exercise stress test.
Give dobutamine,
increase that heart rate,
check it out with
an echocardiogram.
So what is the major
thing we think about?
Evidence. How well does
the drug work based
on good randomized
controlled trials? Long
-term dobutamine is
associated with decreased
survival. So this is
a stopgap measure.
Okay, let's see how
you can work through
this problem I'm
going to give you.
We're going
to compare the
cardiovascular effects
of norepinephrine,
epinephrine, and
isoproterenol.
Norepinephrine,
epinephrine, isoproterenol.
So we'll go in the
order that we actually
looked at them in
this lecture. So
we'll start with
epinephrine first. and
we remember that
epinephrine is right
so the betas are it
has more potency on
the betas than on
the alphas but it's
got very strong
activity on all of them
so we're using
10 micrograms per
milliliter per minute
sorry which is a
relatively low dose so
we can see the effects
on all of these
different receptors.
So activation of
the beta-1 receptors
is going to
increase the heart
rate, here epinephrine is
administered here,
heart rate goes up.
And the systolic blood
pressure is going
to go up as the
heart rate goes up
and pushes, increases
cardiac output,
pushes the blood
against the vessels and
the systolic blood
pressure goes up.
But meanwhile,
activation of the beta
-2 receptors will
cause vasodilation in
the skeletal muscle
vascular beds here.
So diastolic pressure
will go down,
DBP down,
SBP up.
So the the average here
is pretty flat, and
as a result, it's not
going to stimulate
reflex tachycardia.
So what else
is happening?
Peripheral
resistance goes
down. Not a lot,
a little bit.
Oops, excuse me.
All right,
norepinephrine now.
Norepinephrine is alphas.
It has the greatest
affinity for the
alpha receptors less
affinity for the betas
but still strong so
we administer the
norepinephrine let's
say right here causes
heart rate it causes
the blood pressure to
go up that's our alphas
causes the diastolic
blood pressure to go
up again the alphas
as we get that generalized
basal constriction
throughout the body
and clearly the
peripheral resistance
is definitely going to
go up which is why we
give it for shock oh
but what's happening
with the heart rate
looks down well remember
this is beta 1 we
put the drug into the
vein it's initially
going to cause an increase
in heart rate, which
you don't see here,
but then M2 takes
over as this increase in
mean arterial pressure
causes a reflux, I'll
put it down here,
reflux response.
And what is that
reflux response? That's
the parasympathetic
nervous system
is activated, and
this is the vagus
nerve, M2 receptors,
decrease heart rate.
So that explains why
the heart rate, it
can be no change or it
can be down, decreased,
depending on dosing
and all of that.
So So that explains
why norepinephrine
graphs look the
way they do.
So let's go to
isoproteranol now.
This is beta 1, beta
2, we don't need
to think about beta
3 at the moment.
So betas, administer
the isoproteranol
right here, and it's
going to increase the
heart rate, clearly,
there is going to be
a little bit of increase
possibly in systolic
blood pressure because
of the increase
in the cardiac output
pushing into the
vessels, but with our
beta 2, we're going
to get a decrease
in diastolic blood
pressure, decreased
diastolic blood pressure.
So the mean arterial
pressure goes down,
the peripheral
resistance goes down,
and we get reflex
response but what would
be the reflex response
to a decrease increase
heart rate so we get
the beta 1 for the
heart rate and the
reflex response on the
heart rate and the heart
rate for isopraternol
goes up much more
than we see with the
other two drugs. And
what can that lead to?
It can lead to
arrhythmias.
So I hope you see how
to think this through
by looking at the
actions on all of the
various receptors and
how they work together
and what the reflex
response might be.
So I have comparisons
here of the
different actions.
I'm not going to
read them read
through them again.
And we'll do a little
check your knowledge.
The chart illustrates
the cardiovascular
drug X, which activates
autonomic receptors.
Okay, so let's see
what's happening here.
This is the control,
so that means
the starting
point was no drug.
Systolic blood
pressure in this
patient goes up
a little bit.
Sorry, it goes
down, right?
Decrease systolic
blood pressure.
Diastolic blood pressure
goes down quite a bit.
And heart rate goes
from 60 to 120.
So it doubles, double
the heart rate.
So, a big
increase in heart
rate. What's
it going to be?
Decreased systolic
blood pressure,
decreased diastolic,
not much change
in the systolic
blood pressure,
decreased diastolic
blood pressure quite
a bit, and a marked
increase in the
heart rate, which is
even at tachycardia.
So, which one is it?
Well, if it was
the alphas, that
would be a big
increase in blood
pressure, systolic
and diastolic.
If it was alpha
1, alpha 2, and
beta 1, so that's
norepinephrine,
it would be an increase
in systolic blood
pressure and diastolic
blood pressure.
Obviously, it's
not muscarinic.
So that leaves C. It
has to be the betas.
And here's our
summary, which
I'm not going
to read to you.
And here's the check
your knowledge questions.
And that
concludes part one
of the Sympasso memetics.